Watch Charles1997.
Thank you
Thank youWe could just not take this round
serious.
So you got any questions you need to take
care ofNo that's not a quick mission.
Where we can move aroundYou know what I'm
saying it's hard to play with you no I don't
mind playing with you.
ButYou got to meet me halfway Charlie cuz
I'm not as good as you at this game and
you're leaving me behind.
Like great we get it you're better than it's
cool greatBut play with us Michael Jordan.
Do you like skin you're not dark skin girl
But you're not dark skin but your light skin
Please
You're being annoyingBut it's okay though.
Sing your song Charlie
But I'm getting ready to seeSee you on
Sunday.
Got the second whooped up
Got a third one
But when I say I done got so many fucking
wolf quotes
When did the bunny foot
OneOne more we need two total.
You brought the what you call it back to
base right the whoopingOkay.
I'm not going to win some parts
And I'm about to go out and say 45
I want to do is to Quest
Too much
Merry Christmas
Dummy
I'm
I don't know why I always like to get the
Sundial but I just like it cuz I need to
know when I need to get home I don't want to
talk about the things the rain
We need to go get metal
Cuz I don't think both of us should get
itWhen it berries around the.
Weekends
I know it's my channel so what
Bro if you don't stop walking over this
evening
Flowers
GoodYeah.
Oh my GodI like the little.
One package
Can I get one of your reward right now
I'm just kidding I got you let me get to the
base and I got to eat and I got to
Decided I'm taking it serious
We're looking like perfect just enough for
the upgrade to get theWhat you call it now
we need 10 more.
So
I thinkI think I'm going to take this one
too. Cuz I'm a greedy.
Yeah but I ain't going for it
I'm just close enough to run back if I get
in trouble
And if not then I start with a head start
for todayOh never mind cuz I'm hungry.
It looks like I started todayNot really cuz.
Because I'm full right now.
I have to go back anyway
And I got another one somewhere but we got a
bike
Times over
You already bought the Crock-PotRight.
I'm going to do it but firstGet some of
these food up.
It's in like a plan another free on it I
mean wine
If you want to put the thing down I can't do
it no more if that's cool with you
Crock-Pot songNow we immediately need a.
CompanyI'm going to make it.
Oh we should get that biofuel thing
Is it still
Palazzo gunNot reloaded how many bullets you
got.
You got 17 total
Okay you got more than me so I'm going to
take this
Did you get the stews you got one on you
Bro do you stop in two and one on you maybe
two I got two on me right now
And I got two at the baseIt's supposed to be
in your Envy.
I got 20Bullets. 6 + 1420.
Oh so you got 29 bullets
Okay so the next one go to me unless we
shoot and you shoot more than me
But I also got this rifle too I don't know
what to say about it I got 13 bullets in it
But I don't be liking it I think it's
slower41 seconds I ain't really. When we got
what we need to say what's up.
Are we already got that then I got to get my
lightning right bro
Get my food up off the floor
Okay well get them free sometime
Oh and we already got to run a Wood Ranch
storage you just didn't put it upYou didn't
want to put it out.
The biopianNo.
Man I know what we want to do with the wood
might want to just stack it up
First I don't make it back in time
I'm sorry 5:30What.
I say three-23 in the bulletsAnd three in
the gun and 20 in your pocket.
Yeah just add them so I got 26All right. So
how much you got.
Perfect you take thisI don't know why I just
do it all the way over there.
Wrestling
I got a gym from this one
Yeah I'm not going home
It makes sense
Good thing I brought the shoes see that's
why I got two screws on you like what would
happen right now
Feel like I got everything but something
tell me I did let me check the map
Damn
Still need to go that way
Remember yourself
Yeah we're not coming home tonight in a row
I hope you don't need me tonight
Clock it
Fire stuff
I feel like I should be taking this a lot
more seriously
And we're going to be attacked tonight
I can't boss neither one of these things
that's crazy what's at least get over
hereLet's shop these guys.
And these guys going to shoot too
All right I shot the shooting one just stay
away from the other guys I got help I got
help
Stupid
Yeah
I want both of themSo. Look at how many
students we got over here.
Four that's a lotWhen it only takes two for
a whole day for and we got three in the pot.
Too.
Day 20No.
We can't put the phone
We need 20 metal 30 woodWe got 13 so we need
17 Wood.
And we need 13 metal Focus the metal I can
get the wood easy around not easy but I can
get them out of the wood
Ain't even some extended what you're
callingThank you.
All right choices but here we go
Never mind didn't take nearly as much as I
thought
So we need 10 more minutes
Or upgrade
So we still need four more wood
That boy right now a bowl as fuckThat must
have forgot what game was playing.
Me
Right now
It's maybe one more alarm come on tree it's
got to be some clips
What's going on I got to go
Right now
Oh he don't care if you inside theOkay.
I thought I was safe cuz I was in the line
noYou're not safe.
If somebody were going to give me I was
supposed to help you deserve me welcome
My God damn
What's upI am too.
I ain't got a badass though you got a
bandageOkay I'll come in the morning.
No
I took the alpha look that was about to kill
me about one here and right here that's why
nothing's around meI already killed the
awful.
The Apple will meet over thereAnd I was like
I'm safe and kill them. I'm like.
Like I might you know what I'm saying like
I'm distressing cuz I almost died I
literally didn't have anything left and then
I got hit by like crazy part is I thought
about
Like taking the med kit and healingBut now
I'm glad I didn't.
Cuz now I have the Mad kid to help meAnd let
me check around to see if there's a chest
over here too.
It's not but it's another bandage too so
it's a bandage animatedAnd a cake.
I should have ate the cake
It's that Apple will he threw me by surprise
I don't know the alcohol up over there
And I saw the man kid and I kept staying
around and I thought it was a chest over
here cuz it was near the camp but I really
should have did but it ain't nothing over
here worth dying over
Could have came back later for itEspecially
cuz I was trying to go deathless.
That's my goal right now
That's not why I'm trying to take it slow
that's just the pace I play this game at I'd
like to like complete everything pick up
everything I need get the food thing so I'm
not hungry and done and then move around
like
That we can get to multiplyChallenge here's
the thing.
You keep trying to get like play the most
efficient way and I feel your brother I
still don't care about no damn beds I
already put the beds up only thing I care
about
To keep you from the game
But overall you know why you know where
It's cuz I left aloneI should have stayed
with my body.
Or worried
Only let me go get this chestLet's kill
this. This thing.
Oh that's so perfect the spear and the rifle
go perfect together
Cuz I sent some metal stuff on the floorSee
Andy's flowers if you want them.
Fuel
All right well I guess we got to hit this
guy
I'm playing with this s bro
To put it on me to eat it
All right I got to go cuz I'm about to
startAnd we're getting attacked tonight I
ain't even got time to kill that offer I
wish I did.
I'm heading back to the house tonight
We got to get back they about to come attack
us
Oh I'm starvingOh oh I'm almost fucking
bitch.
If you can't see cuz they're right there I
was like I was hoping it I was hoping it I
think I pressed r instead of E
I'm kind of mad so I ain't going to lie to
youA good job that's our new best.
With me and youAlmost lasted a whole month.
Ready for Doctor leave us
One doctor leave usWe need that Explorer
energy.
It's a treat
It makes you it gives you no it's a
challenge oh extra perk from any class
How do I get to the second level
Mister know it all
How do I get to the second levelFor this.
Images
No food nothing come on
What's it that's not him
Stay playing games bro broIs it fool or is
it true.
Okay so you don't want to play with us you
want to play with your friend
In a stage act call it a Maybach tripping
cuz big fat
Here we go out there
Not really worried about a random testIf you
guys have to get it cuz I can still get the
stuff done.
You was good todayWhat's up cash.
Cashel and
You can't hear me
Good morning boss man
Fighting ain't nobody tell him to fight with
that's what they don't know that's really
the truth
And it's either way
Shit
I'll have to make a couple of minutes before
we leave there
140 1:35 okay and the most badass cuz they
attacked twice
What the what the what the with the What's
called the billboard
Not today
My cousin Brian
You know who I'm talking about
His oldest son Brian
ButWe we were already on our way somewhere
so I can be late. I can do I'll get on your
daddy.
Because then Uncle Victor whatever you call
them now
ActuallyI got two.
Yeah I got two whoops
How many Woodfield I mean how manyHow many.
Banana puts we need.
We don't got noneWow what have we been
doing.
Right for Bed Bath
It pulls up to bed bath water now now we're
now doing the Best Buy order right it sends
us
To the drop off
Location I'm thinking it's still a drop off
location no it's not even the drop off
location it was a whole random ass location
in in the in the title of the where it says
like Best Buy it the address up there
The address that was on their head it had no
relations to the store nor the person that
ordered it why would you say dress on there
No clue like I just wasted y'all wasting the
time
Okay babe was on the toilet
So I don't think I'm going to just pay at
the pump I forgot to prepare attention
I told him I was like the guy in the store
she's not there the door is locked I'm
paying at the pump right he was busy because
he asked this to me okay
The door is locked I'm paying at the pump
right now and went to clean the window
I'll look back at the 1950
S
Tonight
Irritation
I don't live there I really live around the
corner of the street in like down
In like down some hills
Right and if you take it to them Uber will
be like you're too far from your drop off
and can't drop it off
Okay that's not the drop off location so now
it's easier for them to say I can get my
order
Okay
And so what do you do you just don't give it
to me
Super call customer supportThey will either
cancel it.
But I was like but wait if I if they cancel
it isn't that going to go towards my
cancellation
Percentage cuz you can't cancel up to turn
them out if you can't see if you keep
canceling that means you're still in order
So right now we had 13% and that's not
because I would still didn't want it that
was just because one day it was raining hard
as fucking I couldn't see until now I got
like five orders I'm canceling that bitch
she was at 8% until the other day I decided
to sign up for like the order and it was
like 23 dollars to pick up and drop off the
air like
Five different stops and I don't want to
take it no moreSo I canceled it so that
added five fucking orders to my cancellation
rate.
So now I'm at 13%And how's the highest you
can get it to you.
'll be okay so I don't think I'll be kicked
off I'm not getting I'm not canceling the
order
They did not sayVery. They did not say what
verified.
They did not tell me or him to verify the
order
And we did we did that highWe said what do
we say.
Somebody else picked it up the time
excessive wait time I put excessive wait
time and it canceled the order
Right but we already have the food
It was the first of all that was all black
man working Wingstop it was nothing but s in
there of course they wasn't going to verify
anything
Who you picking up we just dropped some
chicken it's going to be about 10 or 15
minutes
Style
I'll pay that shit I definitely baby
Potatoes let me get that Baby Come Back
Home
Oh my picture came out lovely with the glow
in the dark knight
Even even the the line set up in the
middleIn the circle the circle part.
Of the windowAnd the lines of the window.
S
Helped the glow in the dark garden
Bro yeah it's nicotine nicotine
I don'tI don't. It's no good boy.
Smiley face
They wouldn't FDA approved
Here
Flow
The bottom only
Going to talk to waitAnd it and we're going
to text.
Just go home
I can pick it up I'll be havingWhen I
couldn't.
When I couldn't drag it because I woke up
and almost nothing
Man I wouldn't mind it
Alfredo sauce
On one piece of coolBut we need to ugly
survival for a job and down.
In a restaurantI feel bad for you. People.
Nobody cares
To get that
Well I'm about to dieI'm about to die.
I knew itWon't be too bad.
What is wildfire
You don't want to do that part
Ner
What should we do it no
NoWe got to save Aria why are we purposely
dying.
Bro
Is it letting you join back
And I mean
Wait a minute waitWhat are you doing here.
Things to do
It
So close
Oh I see the problem nowYeah definitely not.
Too far.
I love you
Let me shut up
Idiot I'm never trying to catch me again
It is
NoPlease.
You got to be kidding meI just checked me a
joke.
I'm about to open it now you don't know
Anna Lee I'm back in life
I'm back
Oh sorry we got a oh I ain't got no I ain't
got nothing to protect myself
Did you just brotherWere you thinking
clearly.
How you going to invite meOh brother this
guy sing.
HappyOh wait I got this wildfire.
Running through the wildfire
I'm going for itIt's not even hurting them.
All right I did itBut it's okay if it's
love.
No
Body took a sweater around the world
Surely like Jackie
Shoes
I'm just thinking of a snack we call
Let me see
It is a chance
I know I took it but it had to get itA good
act.
OrThey just buy me.
I can't give you a good app but only give me
a song
Good at
You're making militaryActivity.
Are we getting cookiesI'm.
I'm dead as hell
Running for my life cuz I don't have a clue
where the fucking fire is
It
They want to know about itThis afternoon.
That's all the good the only good cookies
they got in it OreosAnd my cookies.
Mother Butters
Why don't let you chop these
Are
If you didn't use it thenIt wasn't my bill
wasn't that look like.
Whatever youDon't be careful shit. Cuz you
need to be too we can talk cuz I'm tired of.
Aren't you talking about are youBaby.
Batman thereI just got my first off of
Woodville.
Ar
Can I go to the store and tell you all the
kids do they haveNo.
Candy
Cuz life is like a box of chocolates
You never know what you're going to get
Died at the wrong time
But you Circle the five one
I can't even say that I open the chest
Life
Life is like a box of chocolates
And you never know what you're going to
getLive.
Is lifeA box. Of chocolate.
And you never know
Would you are goingTo get.
Up
We technically
Not getting no oil no cookies
That's orders I mean that's notOut of the
police.
Because you playing again
One last one
Lady
Do you know how to do it
Yeah
Making burgers we know we not
The cheese longer than Burgers that's why
we're doing alfredo
They got me some expire
Why do you keep saying thatThe ground beef
was frozen.
I understand completely it says use or
freeze by right
I'm asking a questionWell next time you look
at it see if it says use or freeze but.
And you'll see it saysWe Gucci.
Got a wolf pill
Ow please
I listen to the victory wow
CharlieI've got seven.
That's why you loaded up the the fireAnd boy
about to take over.
Tell us okay we're used to it though
I was like we didn't even need it for other
than this we ain't even got all the rabbits
yet
I'm the closest to the bankDoesn't matter
bro.
We still don't got rabbit foot
You got a little fucking fire
Oh my God one woke up
Running shot up on my bulletsAnd I don't
even see a rabbit inside of me so.
This was a
I want you to
That too
Just another beautiful day object
It's
OkayMe.
About Uncle Jake
BecauseQuotes.
It says I'll be on it
50 did you wear my shoes
What no I don't know
Well I'm not working in abandoned
I'm going to open on social media
Do you have any did you get any JapaneseNo
no.
It behind me
Are you trying to find a Ruby Tuesday
YeahWhy not I don't see it you should. Have
been a cool chest.
I don't know if she enjoyYou got a crossbow.
Give me something
I wanted to restart since we didn't get a
good mother fucking rabbit I ain't going to
run
Not right now fool I was talking about now
like to this game
Okay we'll go get this text me right there
And I can't even say I want to fall offWho's
coming with me.
He gave me a revolver
VirginiaCool.
ErI got a good time. I can grab stuff.
I got to work right hereNothing. Let me know
if you see anything cuz I can grab it.
I think we got to go get wood
You're going to be your feetNobody want to
get nobody wants to give up pictures.
And everything I want to see
So far
And why would you up front when I have full
health
You you already got one
Yeah
??
Hey I put not the nine in I only took one
from you if it mean that much to you I'll
get it back
?
We all knowWhy.
I've been dancing
Don't
Are you ready to go
I know you are
Live we just need stoves
I went to a raw meat
I got one over here near me
It's sitting right by the kid
You're alive already
NothingAny way to get both.
Wait
Yeah
Let me get the first two
Make all the students
Let me put the coffee right here I could
have made an automatic recipe
Ready
Define bucket the fight
Song
Or you think reset are in one morning
I found something
But what I'm about to do with you
You wanted to goTo bed.
If I do this I could provide bullshit
All right we lost
You
Security service and you put it in the
fridge
It's too hard to cut it in half rightIt's
too hard or is it squishy.
I'm cutting face
We'll see if my coffee
You can fight with random one person you
know
Yeah
They're not supposed
1 2 3 4
You at one two three
You're looking at my old accountYes. I have
a truck.
Machine
My brother have a priceSend.
Who are you
Doing
??
What you doFor children.
Cuz it's notYou got me added.
Haha
Housing fishHow long do you want to be
eating alfredo sauce.
It took me to theWe can see his truck.
Where you atE.
That's
He startedHave you check to make sure the
bottom not burning.
Jennifer hotspot job center
Yes please
But she was wondering when I came back
Yeah
I doSomething.
So you do need to get in there and get your
part
Cuz you shouldn't have left without it I
could easily punish you the whole picture
cuz of that I'm not going to but I could
We already worked out that we was doing half
and half each for the rest of it right
Now pay you doing
Daddy all the password
Menu
But Chris is in there
What do you mean you don't knowIf it's
ready. Is the meat.
Is the meat squishy it is the protein
squishy
It's going to be hard in the middle
You could rock with it to get started if you
wanted itBut you could also wait.
I don't think it's a differenceBut you could
act gbt.
Oh
It's hot
Why do you keep doing that what's wrong with
what I said
Okay just making sure
He put
YeahNo water in my front so oh yeah.
Because yeah no water on the water
You need a game back now
It's not worried about this game
Yep it missing off the charger too
I was saying all I did was turn the game on
and the controller wasn't even connected to
the thing so
Then I turned it back off cuz I don't want
to get on my channel
BrotherI tried on something different to see
if it's nothing.
Was working nowI'm going to have to.
Listen to sports
Y'allHello.
Hello
Created three balls
I got three bowlsAnd I'll let him out there
is both big. Bigger than out.
It's the charger
Give me the
Bruno Mars
What if I let you drive on the highway then
you go to the countryIf I let you drive
you'll go to the country.
No I was like don't forget I will let you
too that's 2 hours of driving
Football
TomorrowEarly morning. Everybody going.
Everybody goingLet me have to cry.
I know me either
If I don't want to go when I got to goYou
got to go.
Hey Jay you're just not you're not even
funny
Nope
BraNo. You wish.
Come here you're not here
What beat you
Don't use my brotherCall him friend. Even
though it's a girlfriend.
About sleepYou don't call me nothing so shut
up monkey.
And stop being annoyingIt's what I punch you
like.
This controlling problem thanks doing wrong
I need to do Square
I did ask thought I put the meat on
Why not like if it start out and ready just
throw it under put it on medium it's really
simple then cover it with the top
When you start hearing itThen it's too late
for you to have started flipping it.
If Charlie put it in there Chris go mix it
So I put it in there and smash it down and
put it on mediumPut the top on it and you
Gucci.
You should smell like me no more
And put some of those onions in there do you
know what I'm talking about or not
I assuming
Big long tire center and she's singing
Last yearHarrisburg Apartments.
People talking
Don't like
The meeting the pot begins
Yeah I should have just let Chris do to me
actually
Why are you not doing the meat you actually
know how to do the ground beefOkay so. Okay.
You need to show Charlie how to do
itCharlie.
You are to learnAnd anything look funny call
me.
No
It was not done
The inside is still not done
It's difficult
ReallyImportant.
I love how you're playing in the kitchenI
love how y'all line right at me.
I love how y'all still doing too much
Soon as you come back
PleaseYes.
Both of y'all already
BarleyYes.
It's
Episode of Dragon Ball Z
I'll tell you another video
We got water
Eagle captain
I don't know what else
Oh I open it ohOkay.
Feeling
Google
Can we put the meat back in the freezer
No we need to put it back in the freezer so
we can stop the time again
Okay
Explain
Yes
Sorry
I know it's okay
I wasn't
Advance Furniture
Don't think about Parkway by myself please I
don't cuz I don't you know them with cheese
you don't come up with you
No I don't want you and I run out onThat
place.
This
ShoeGet it get it. Shoot.
Behind it
I didn't feel no money but not at all got
away from me
First shotAnd I'm going to be a child to
make it 10 times harder on myself.
I don't have to worry about people
Right
Pretty approaching about how we care
The trolls first tryThat again. Puts that.
I'm getting a workout nowHaving a hotel on
Big Orange.
I might not be able to be able to go
Externally getting hardIt's. It's a goat.
Yeah you ain't noThe ugly made it to go
yeah.
It's about
You going to miss it well I think you got a
drink some of that grease out and then put
the sauce on it
On another video
No I'm cooking I'm cooking cookies
From Hunger
No I was trying to get a wolf pillThat's
what you did.
Something
Why you talking cuz I'm talking to beat you
want to say they ain't going to say it's
crazy
Yeah I said
I got everything
I hope you die
Possible
I'm a vegan
Boots
Okay now you want
The date the kids give you a bummy
Bear
Song
Oh another wolf though I don't know what I'm
going to do with it
Oh I'm so dead
About you
4 minutes
And I thoughtTo.
PedestrianEye Associates.
I got both good action booster he said I
can'tMiss you okay.
Thank you Chris but I wasn't talking to you
bro
I wouldn't ask anywayWhy did you get up
here.
I'm going to be
Five nowYeah.